[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour un
nouveau numéro de sens public notre
émission mobilisée comme toutes les
équipes de Public Sénat pour vous faire
vivre de l'intérieur ces deux semaines
d'examens du texte de la réforme des
retraites justement en ouvrira notre
débat dans une minute sur la majorité LR
et les premiers articles adoptés régimes
spéciaux index senior et CDI spécial
pour sauvegarder l'emploi des plus de 60
ans la droite sénatoriale imprime sa
marque sur le texte du Gouvernement et
le fameux article 7 sur le report de
l'âge légal devrait être examiné ce
mardi dans la soirée et puis dans notre
second débat on va évaluer la puissance
du mouvement syndical avant une journée
ou certains veulent mettre l'économie
française à genoux
partout c'est de désorganiser au maximum
la production et si la question c'est de
savoir si on veut mettre à genoux
l'économie française la réponse elle est
oui
combien de personnes dans les rues
demain combien de jours de grève
reconductible avec quelles conséquences
sur les débats parlementaires ont
décortiquera les enjeux de ce 7 mars
2023 date historique cochée par tous
depuis des semaines mais d'abord grâce à
Samia de chir et Jonathan Dupriez on
vous résume cette journée de débat au
Sénat
quatrième jour de l'examen les débats se
font plus animés au Sénat restez
silencieuse ce week-end la droite est
enfin rentrée dans l'arène pour défendre
ses propositions sur la réforme des
retraites comme le CDI senior un contrat
exempté de cotisations familles pour
l'embauche d'un salarié en fin de
carrière son adoption ce matin s'est
faite contre la vie de la gauche mais
après des échanges dont la qualité a été
saluée sur tous les bons ils sont des
débats qui sont sereins qui sont apaisés
on va enfin si j'ose dire au fond du
sujet et ça c'est essentiel pour la
vitalité de la démocratie parlementaire
parce que l'image qu'a donné l'Assemblée
nationale pendant ces 15 jours d'examen
de ce texte essentiel pour l'avenir des
Français c'est une image déplorable
apaisés mais relativement long sur les
3700 amendements il en reste un peu
moins de 3000 ans discussions dont une
grande majorité déposée par la gauche
qui prend tout son temps pour les
défendre laisser pleinement les
parlementaires avoir la liberté et le
temps de s'exprimer je pense que ça
c'est nécessaire donc il y a pas
d'obstruction on fait juste notre rôle
de parlementaire l'obstruction c'est le
parle c'est le gouvernement qui la
pratique en faisant en sorte qu'on est
obligé de débattre dans un petit délai
jour et nuit si le rythme des
discussions n'accélère pas il sera
difficile d'aller au bout de l'examen du
texte d'ici le 12 mars à minuit le
rapporteur y croit de moins en moins
vous n’expliquez pas votre amendement
vous profitez de la tribune pour faire
des effets tribunes faut arrêter les
provocations à un moment si on voit que
il y a pas de compréhension de ceux qui
ont déposé ce type d'amendement
répétitif
et qui n'a aucune valeur ajoutée les uns
après les autres faudra en tirer les
conclusions la majorité sénatoriale
prévient pour accélérer les débats elle
est prête à limiter les prises de parole
dans l'hémicycle comme li autorise le
règlement du Sénat pas sûr que cela
suffisait à aller au bout des vins
articles la gauche est fume nous ne
voulons pas le vote de cette loi il y a
aucun doute sur le sujet nous nous y
opposons mais vous savez c'est pas le
rythme du Sénat quel sujet ce qu'est le
sujet c'est l'immense mobilisation qui
aura lieu demain une mobilisation
annoncée comme massive par les syndicats
et dont la gauche sénatoriale espère
qu'elle pourrait affaiblir le soutien de
la droite au projet du gouvernement
je vois tout de suite mes invités
Béatrice Gibelin bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes géographe directrice de la revue
Hérodote Rafael Legendre bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi journaliste
politique à l'opinion Jean Gary
historien
bienvenue et Mathieu croissanto
historialise politique bonsoir et
bienvenue on débat enfin c'est ce qu'on
voyait du fond de cette réforme Béatrice
est-ce que ici au Sénat ce sont pour
vous est-ce qu'on peut aller jusqu'à
deux modèles de société qui s'opposent
entre finalement une droite et une
gauche j'allais dire classique
je pense qu'en fait le Sénat se dit
qu'il a vraiment une un moment un moment
politique à jouer il y a eu une telle
j'avais dit
mascarade à l'Assemblée nationale
faciliter des plaisants ce qui s'est
passé à l'Assemblée nationale et les
Français qui avaient sans le vouloir
j'assiste là-dessus donner une majorité
relative ce ça m'amuse toujours quand on
dit les Français chacun a mis son
bulletin dans l'urne et puis ça a donné
ça mais enfin ils avaient pas prévu que
ce serait ça vous croyez pas
l'intelligence collective en quelque
sorte de situation mais ce qui est
en se disant bah enfin il va y avoir
plus des députés go on pouvait discuter
de rien là on va avoir de la vraie
démocratie parlementaire et on a eu
effectivement un spectacle absolument
déplorable et je pense que pour le Sénat
dont on avait envisagé la suppression il
y a déjà longtemps la revanche est belle
quand même parce que du coup ils
apparaissent comme étant des bons
démocrates la démocratie parlementaire
doit jouer pour ça qu'il faut que la
gauche fasse un peu attention parce que
si elle rejoue l'obstruction même
courtoise comme cela a été dit elle va
accentuer cette image de mauvais
démocrate enfin ou de mauvais joueur
d'une certaine façon alors qu'elle avait
là quelque chose à jouer
Stéphane Larcher qui est quand même
un vieux renard de la politique qui
connaît son Sénat sur le bout des doigts
il va garder la main il a gardé la main
on va évidemment développer tout ça
Raphaël Legendre c'est très fort on le
dit évidemment depuis ce matin sur notre
entrée et depuis plusieurs jours depuis
que le texte est examiné au Sénat elle
ressemble à si mes prendres à celle qui
est votée depuis des années par les
sénateurs ici même et est-ce qu'elle va
si elle passe avec ces amendements
proposés par le sein est-ce qu'elle va
conforter celles et ceux qui disent que
le en même temps d'Emmanuel Macron il
penche de plus en plus vers sa droite ça
très certainement et en même temps c'est
ce qu'on voit depuis le début de la
mandature c'est que les voix de passage
en majorité se font avec la droite et
que ce soit à l'Assemblée nationale ou
au Sénat il se trouve que la droite
évidemment est majoritaire au Sénat donc
c'est avec la droite qu'on négocie mais
c'est également le cas à l'Assemblée
nationale sur beaucoup de textes pas
surtout par exemple Agnès cher réussi à
trouver des voies de passage dans les
énergies renouvelables sur les énergies
renouvelables à l'Assemblée nationale
mais c'est très clairement avec les
républicains qu'Emmanuel Macron peut
naviguer et réussit jusqu'à présent on a
eu une dizaine de 49,3 sur la loi de
finances ce n'est pas une surprise mais
la vraie surprise c'est que sur le reste
des textes des textes de loi qui sont
présentés depuis juillet dernier on est
à plus de six mois et bien ça passe et
ça passe avec le soutien des
républicains jusqu'ici jusqu'ici
effectivement Jean garrigue on est
finalement dans la la promesse d'une
construction parlementaire là en ce
moment dans ce qui se passe depuis 4-5
jours ici au Sénat oui je le crois et il
y a une carte à jouer comme le disait
Béatrice Gibelin pour le pour le Sénat
comme d'ailleurs ils avaient une carte à
jouer au moment de l'affaire Benalla ou
la commission d'enquête la commission
des lois ou à l'Assemblée nationale
avait échoué et et c'était la commission
du Sénat avec Philippe Bas qui avait qui
avait fait le travail et là aujourd'hui
il y a un homme qui est au cœur du jeu
ces gens à l'archet Gérard Larcher qui a
négocié avec le pouvoir exécutif ce que
devrait être le rôle du Sénat qui a plus
à chaque fois insisté auprès de ses
troupes au Sénat auprès de la majorité
LR pour que les choses se fassent pour
qu'on aille au bout de la de la
négociation l'enjeu est important parce
qu'il faut toujours avoir moi en tout
cas depuis le début de de la crise
provoquée par cette réforme j'ai
toujours eu en filigrane cette idée que
on a aujourd'hui une désaffection entre
les citoyens et la classe politique dans
son ensemble et notamment les assemblées
et il y a donc une un enjeu de
relégitimation des assemblées ce qui est
en train de se passer en ce moment avec
un débat quand même beaucoup plus apaisé
et qui ce qui la sans doute savait plus
constructif au Sénat c'est que
précisément c'est le Sénat qui joue ce
qui joue ce rôle de relégitimation alors
dans toutes nos émissions évidemment
donne la priorité au direct et à ce qui
se passe dans l'hémicycle je vous
propose tiens quelques chiffres reposer
une nouvelle fois le décor il y a eu
plus de 4700 amendements qui ont été
déposés à midi environ retiré depuis ce
qui était prévu c'est 110 heures de
discussion et ça doit nous mener
jusqu'au 12 mars minuit voilà on a
reposé le décor et on va tout de suite
faire une sorte de premier bilan avec
Quentin Calmette et on dirait que depuis
la salle des conférences avec une
journée Quentin bonsoir qui a été
marquée finalement comme les précédentes
par l'opposition de de deux stratégies
expliquez-nous bonsoir Thomas
effectivement un public snack qui est
tout premier loge on est installé
pendant 11 jours ici avec voilà un
plateau exprès dédié dans la salle des
conférences qui jouent l'hémicycle pour
tout suivre et effectivement on a vu ce
double mouvement vous l'avez dit Thomas
avec deux stratégies différentes entre
la droite et la gauche sénatorielle si
bien que ça donne un rythme d'examen du
texte assez la casquette sur un un celui
d'un moteur diesel un peu mal réglé si
vous me permettez l'analogie avec des
moments où les débats sont vraiment très
intéressants équilibrées aussi entendre
parole on entend la droite et la gauche
et des moments où il y a ces échanges
qui sont plutôt des monologues ou la
gauche sénatoriale dépose des dizaines
d'amendements également demande
d'explication comme cela en série et
donc il fallait pas moins pour que
l'entende certains à droite faire la
reproche d'une forme d'obstruction
cordiale de la part de la gauche écouter
le LR René Paul Savary on l'a entendu
dans un cours extrait dans le sujet de
Samuel de Chiron on l'écoute un peu plus
longtemps
et que l'effet répétitif d'amendement
similaire modifiant simplement un petit
pourcentage un petit pourcentage de
cotisations
supplémentaires et il y a des violences
déviance du débat parlementaire vous
n'expliquez pas votre amendement vous
profitez de la tribune pour faire des
effets tribunes parce que vous savez
qu'on vous regarde et effectivement les
gens nous regardent
voilà en fait ce qui se joue pour la
droite c'est qu'elle ne veut surtout pas
rallonger les débats et les faire
absolument aller vers les articles qui
suivent dans le texte et donc ce silence
et cette obstruction par le silence de
la droite ça agace à gauche écoutez
Fabien gay nous on est sur des nouvelle
piste de financement on vous offre une
palette décidant étrangers entre nous la
majorité du peuple français va vous le
redire demain avec grande force personne
ne veut travailler deux ans de plus
parce que s'il travaille et source
d'épanouissement et de liens social pour
beaucoup de travailleurs et travailleurs
les utiles essentiels de ce pays c'est
aussi source de souffrance psychiques et
physique et donc non on ne veut pas
voler les deux plus belles années et
donc nous pensons qu'il faut avoir un
vrai débat allez arrêter l'obstruction
silencieuse débattez avec nous voilà
Thomas en surveille tout ça donc au plus
près depuis ce studio ici en salle des
conférences notamment sur la journée de
demain elle est cruciale puisque
maintenant les rumeurs qui circulent
disent qu'on va bien examiner l'article
7 celui sur la mesure d'âge dans la
soirée de demain après les manifs Thomas
effectivement est juste une dernière
petite question Quentin pour évaluer il
y a eu combien d'amants là on est en fin
d'après-midi ce lundi 14 aujourd'hui
d'accord donc il y a encore du boulot
quand même parce que si on veut
atteindre les 3000 3700 et quelques et
ça pose effectivement la question
centrale est-ce que cette loi sera votée
je vous propose un vrai chapitre
consacré à cette question dans ce débat
Jean Gary c'est intéressant c'est ce que
vient de nous raconter quand un calmé
c'est les deux quand emploi le même
terme de l'obstruction
sauf que il faut arrêter la langue de
bois effectivement ce que font
actuellement les sénateurs socialistes
c'est de l'obstruction quand on joue sur
deux trois phrases de l'amendement etc
qu'on refait les amendes quasiment 6
similaires c'est ça s'appelle de
l'obstruction parlementaire alors ça
n'atteint pas les proportions qu'on a eu
à l'Assemblée nationale je crois qu'il y
a eu 13000 amendements on a eu le temps
de d'examiner que deux articles de la
loi mais c'est quand même cette
stratégie là sauf qu'elle est j'allais
dire à l'image du Sénat elle est une
obstruction un peu feutrée
endomite puisque on a accepté quand même
de éventuellement que à partir de demain
on puisse examiner ce fameux article 7
qui est au centre de la loi donc on va
pas aussi loin et puis d'un autre côté
l'explication de texte que donne le
rapporteur me semble tout à fait il a
bien expliqué ce que c'était une une
obstruction qui permet aussi c'est vrai
de on l'a vu avec le député le sénateur
pardon communise serait bien gay qui
permet aussi d'exprimer une sensibilité
politique ça peut jouer aussi son rôle
d'explication mais là les Français ont
un peu de mal à comprendre parce que
parce qu'ils ont vu ce que ça donnait à
l'Assemblée nationale ils ont vu les
dégâts que ça pouvait mais Béatrice
blanche je suis pas sûr que ça passe à
pas un peu sous les radars d'une grande
partie des des Français évidemment mais
quand même on peut quand l'argument de
l'obstruction silencieuse c'est pas
inintéressant parce que on a reproché à
l'Assemblée non mais bon j'explique que
tu vois tout le monde frérot
ça a été la critique faite sur les
débats à l'Assemblée il y a pas eu de
vraies discussions sur le fond du texte
pour discuter il faut être que si il y a
du silence en face il y a pas de
discussion voyez ce que je veux dire
vous êtes là à nous faire des
amendements
à qui mieux pour rien changer bon bah
nous notre stratégie ou notre tactique
si vous voulez c'est se taire parce que
si on vous alimente aussi on va pas
avancer or visiblement on veut avancer
donc c'est vrai que pour eux ils sont
dans le vide si personne ne réagit c'est
à la limite c'est pas amusant quoi parce
que ce qui est bien c'est quand il y a
de la frustration en fait la frustration
ce qui est bien c'est quand il y a de la
joute et à ce moment-là on peut rebondir
et là on est au spectacle quand il y a
personne qui vous alimente c'est
nettement moins marrant quoi donc alors
sur le feu le le fond du texte écoutez
ce que ce qu'on dit le socialiste le
sénateur socialiste évidemment Assouline
il veut renommer cette réforme des
retraites
ce qui nous arrive ici c'est une réforme
qui maintenant pourrait porter le nom de
Born retaillaux c'est une réforme qui
est soutenue et qui va être soutenu dans
cette émission par la droite sénatoriale
et par le gouvernement et donc nous
notre stratégie va être très combatif en
écho avec le mouvement syndical avec
cette mobilisation qui convoque majorité
de Français jusqu'à présent mais en même
temps en jouant notre rôle de
parlementaire c'est-à-dire en
argumentant défendant des amendements en
étant dans la pédagogie et donc on va
accueillir Steve Jourdain sur ce plateau
bonsoir Steve heureux jeune papa
bienvenue merci bienvenue à vous
montrez-moi votre mine ouais ça va vous
avez récupéré ça va bien alors
effectivement la question que à laquelle
on va répondre ensemble grâce à vous et
ensuite grâce à nos experts c'est
jusqu'où l'examen de ce texte va aller
est-ce que cette loi va pouvoir être
votée ici faut bien comprendre Thomas
que rien n'impose au sénateur d'aller au
bout c'est-à-dire d'examiner tous les
articles de cette réforme si dimanche
soir à minuit certains articles n'ont
pas été discutés et bien c'est le
gouvernement qui reprendra la main et
choisira le texte qu'il soumettra à une
commission mixte paritaire qui réunit
députée et sénateur on a d'ailleurs déjà
une date pour cette commission qui sera
chargée de mettre les deux chambres
d'accord ce sera la semaine prochaine 15
mars à l'Assemblée nationale et donc la
droite on l'a bien compris veut que ce
soit son texte qui soit voté dimanche
soir oui la majorité sénatoriale veut
imposer sa réforme au gouvernement il
faut donc aller au bout de son examen et
procéder à un vote sur l'ensemble du
projet c'est ce qui a rappelé Bruno
Retailleau hier moi je pense que il faut
voter la loi le Parlement c'est pas fait
seulement pour discuter pour débattre on
n'est pas des groupes de paroles on n'a
pas été élus pour former tous ensemble
un groupe de parole notre job c'est de
voter la loi sinon on alimente l'anti
parlementarisme pourquoi c'est ce qu'a
fait l'Assemblée nationale parce que que
voit français lorsque il voit que on a
des débats que en plus à l'Assemblée
nationale ils se sont écharpés c'était
incroyable c'était une guignolisation
bah ils se disent mais à quoi ça sert
tout ça il débattent ils débattent ils
votent même pas bon ça c'est pour la
droite quelle est la stratégie de la
gauche et bien elle est sur une ligne de
crête la gauche beaucoup de choses vont
dépendre de l'ampleur de la mobilisation
demain ce qui est certain et bien c'est
que les différents groupes qui composent
la gauche du Sénat veulent débat de
l'article 7 vous en parlez tout à
l'heure l'article 7 qui prévoit le recul
de l'âge de départ à la retraite mais
faut-il examiner les 13 articles qui
suivent faut-il participer au vote sur
l'ensemble du texte prévu dimanche soir
certains pensent que non car ça serait
faire un cadeau à la droite et au
gouvernement d'autres estiment qu'il
faut au contraire afficher clairement la
couleur en bon socialiste Patrick Kanner
tente de faire la synthèse écoutez-le je
souhaite que le débat aille jusqu'au
bout et encore une fois le jusqu'au bout
c'est le 12 mars à minuit et ce n'est
pas de notre fait si ce jusqu'au bout
est prévu à l'avance à la fin puisqu'on
nous impose un rythme de débat qui ne
nous convient pas et même si la droite
veut avoir son texte et bien s'il n'est
pas voté et bien ça affaiblira
globalement le texte à la précision que
même si la gauche parvient à faire durer
les débats la droite dispose de
plusieurs outils pour accélérer l'examen
du texte avec l'article 38 du Règlement
du Sénat elle peut par exemple décider
de limiter le temps de parole par
amendement ou pas article c'est un
dispositif qui aurait même déjà dû être
utilisé son certain élu qui estiment
qu'on a perdu beaucoup trop de temps
depuis jeudi et dernier bref Thomas tout
est très politique dans cette réforme
même le tempo de son examen au Parlement
merci Steve pour toutes ces explications
Raphaël Legent t'as peut-être un mot de
cet article
38 alors c'est le règlement du Sénat
c'est ce que disait Steve à l'instant
c'est pas forcément sur tout le texte
qui serait utilisé ça peut être sur un
seul un seul amendement ou un seul
article c'est ça
peut estimer qu'une fois qu'il a été
défendu et qu'il y a eu un contenteur
que ce qui était contre c'était exprimé
on pouvait arrêter il faut qu'il y ait
les deux discussions
et il y a un vote de l'ensemble de
l'hémicycle ainsi debout si les besoins
après le vin le vote à main levé pardon
et les discussions s'arrêtent on passe à
l'abonnement suivant et alors si vous
deviez vous mouiller un petit peu là ce
soir est-ce que vous pensez qu'on ira au
bout du texte alors on ira ça c'est la
grande question moi je non je ne me
mouillerai pas pardon de vous décevoir
ce qu'on peut faire c'est un décryptage
sur le pourquoi d'abord on attend cet
article 7 demain on a cette journée de
mobilisation
importante qui est attendue et ce qui
attendait les l'aile gauche de
l'hémicycle et bien c'est d'utiliser la
puissance de ce mouvement et de cette
journée de mobilisation de demain pour
essayer d'appuyer sur le vote de
l'article 7 utilisez la puissance de la
rue pour dire non ce délai ce report de
l'âge légal de départ nous n'en voulons
pas écouter français d'où très
probablement l'examen de l'article 7 dès
demain soir c'est quelque chose qui va
aussi à Renaissance pourquoi parce que
cet article sera adopté quoi qu'il en
soit avec les LR qui le propose depuis
plusieurs années déjà et donc cela
permettra aussi à la majorité
parlementaire pas assez natorial mais
dans l'ensemble et à l'exécutif de dire
écoutez en dépit de la pression de la
rue nous avons réussi à faire voter
cette mesure qui passera donc et les LR
quant à eux ainsi que la majorité
d'ailleurs tape sur un essoufflement du
mouvement en fin de ce mode en fin de
semaine ce qui permettrait d'accélérer
un peu les discussions autour de
l'article la gauche quoi qu'il en soit
ne veut pas de ce projet de loi donc
aller jusqu'au bout
ne l'intéresse pas forcément si vous
discutez avec quelques sénateurs
socialistes ils vous disent qu'on
pourrait aussi le faire tout aussi bien
dans un souci démocratique
parce que comme l'avait indiqué
Gabrielle Attal il y a quelques jours le
Sénat ça n'est pas la ZAD mais la
République et que donc vous avez une
majorité de parlementaires qui sont
assez ouverts à aller jusqu'au bout des
discussions oui des deux côtés il y a
quand même quelque chose qui change par
rapport à l'assemblée c'est que les
patrons de la boutique si j'ose dire
c'est la droite et la droite a dit
soutenir la réforme et qu'il fallait
voter la réforme donc la droite joue
aussi de son image là-dedans ne vont pas
jusqu'au bout c'est le texte n'est pas
adopté c'est pas seulement que le
gouvernement voulu aller trop vite ça
c'est vrai c'est pas seulement que il y
a une opposition de la gauche à réforme
c'est que la droite tient pas la
dernière maison qui lui reste entre
guillemets le Sénat donc à mon avis ils
vont jouer de tout les amandes les les
règlements possibles pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir accélérer les débat et puis par
ailleurs parce que ça pose une vraie
question de principe si on a un texte
qui n'est pas adopté à l'Assemblée et un
texte qui n'est pas adopté au Sénat et
que tout se fait dans une commission
mixte paritaire entre cette sénateur et
cette députés et qu'ensuite on va dans
un vote solennel à l'Assemblée et au
Sénat à l'Assemblée si ça passe pas avec
un 49-3 enfin bref on est dans quelque
chose de surréaliste on a qu'on a jamais
connu si si on arrive ici on en arrive
jusque là pour ne pas que que cette loi
soit élaborée en chambre noire et qu'on
soit pour ou qu'on soit contre la loi je
pense que c'est pas bon que ce soit fait
comme ça par des tractations entre des
sénateurs ou des députés mais ça serait
nécessaire en tout cas plus démocratique
que le Sénat la dote voilà qui s'en suit
c'est soit demandé par les députés qui
discuteront avec les ce qui peut pousser
Gérard Larcher bien à utiliser ce fameux
article 38 dont on parle même si en
terme d'image c'est pas idéal c'est pas
idéal parce que une fois mais c'est
arctique par article amendement par
abonnement donc si on arrive à bien le
faire comprendre et si on arrive à
accuser la gauche de l'obstruction avec
des amendements ridicules à ce moment-là
il reprend la main sur l'idée la
démocratie nécessite que de temps en
temps donne un coup d'arrêt à ceux qui
font l'obstruction même cordiale et pour
qu'on puisse discuter cette loi jusqu'au
bout donc si c'est bien manier et on
pense savoir faire pour le faire on peut
lui faire confiance à ce moment-là à la
limite il c'est pas comme si on
empêchait le débat au contraire c'est
pour permettre effectivement d'aller
jusqu'au bout dans une assemblée qui est
quand même aussi représentative des
collectivités territoriales il faut
quand même pas non plus oublier ça c'est
pas votre suffrage universel on a besoin
de de ces électeurs donc pour l'image du
Sénat ce serait catastrophique qu'il
n'arrive pas au bout de cette loi je
pense donc si nécessaire
on prendra l'article 38 si nécessaire
après
il essaiera je pense qu'il essaiera de
ne pas passer en force du tout mais
néanmoins moi je pense qu'on ira au bout
et que le Sénat votera cette tout à fait
pour ce que vous avez dit Mathieu
autrement c'est trop dangereux oui moi
on a parlé tout à l'heure d'une carte à
jouer sur le Sénat mais sur un terrain
strictement politique c'est aussi une
carte à jouer c'est ce qu'on vient de
dire pour les républicains n'oublions
pas la situation actuelle des
républicains ce que ça a donné au moment
à l'Assemblée nationale avec cette
division l'aventure personnelle on va
dire d'Aurélien Pradier enfin la
scission etc et là il y a une carte
parce que comme on le disait tout à
l'heure cette cette réforme elle peut
être totalement annexée par la
République c'est toute la stratégie
discursive de de Retailleau et des
autres de dire mais regardez c'est notre
réforme qui va et qui va passer donc
d'une part il commandait il relégit-il
le poids des républicains qui est un
poids réel d'ailleurs non seulement au
Sénat mais dans les collectivités
territoriales mais en plus il relégitime
je dirais la crédibilité des
républicains la productivité politique
des républicains c'est quand même un
pari intéressant pour eux c'est une
manière de se de se remettre au coeur du
jeu après les échecs de aux élections
présidentielles je trouve que c'est
quand même important mais alors je vais
vous poser la même question à tous Je
commence avec vous à fait le genre
est-ce que vous pensez vraiment que on
s'attend et on va y consacrer toute la
seconde partie de cette émission à une
mobilisation très forte demain peut-être
historique on verra bien mais est-ce que
vous pensez vraiment que cette
mobilisation peut influer sur les débats
à la Chambre haute ici ici au Sénat
c'est le Paris que fait que font les
socialistes les communistes moi j'ai
beaucoup de mal à le croire pour une
raison très simple c'est que l'attention
de l'opinion publique est concentrée sur
un chiffre 64 ans c'est la seule et
unique mesure que retient l'opinion
publique d'un texte plus large qui
compte une vingtaine d'articles mais qui
est d'une technicité absolument affreuse
dans tes si bien que y compris certains
ministres s'ils sont pris les pieds et
que donc c'est le symbole sur lequel
évidemment le gouvernement ne reviendra
jamais c'est le pilier le cœur de la
réforme beaucoup a été beaucoup a été
fait en redistribution déjà le texte a
été très largement sont vraiment des à
l'Assemblée nationale il le saura à
nouveau tout au long de cette semaine au
Sénat mais sur ce point dur qui est
l'abandon de l'âge légal de départ à 64
ans c'est ce que demanderont demain
l'ensemble des personnes qui
manifesteront qui défileront dans les
rues et c'est évidemment le symbole que
souhaite tenir Emmanuel Macron face à la
rue Béatrice bien on va rappeler un
chiffre que qui est l'un des chiffres de
cette journée c'est quand même le nombre
de villes enfin le nombre de
manifestants voilà le nombre de
manifestations prévues demain 265 c'est
quand même assez assez massif
donc on n'est pas
maintenant on verra combien il y aura de
manifestants il y en aura beaucoup de
toute façon c'est annoncé c'est annoncé
à son trompe donc elle est limite on
sera pas surpris ce qui aurait été plus
étonnant c'est que on annonce à million
et qu'on est amis et demi tout le monde
dit on sera amis et demi ou deux
millions ah bon bah oui on a été amélior
et demi d'une certaine façon l'effet
d'annonce il est déjà il est déjà passer
alors moi je ne crois pas du tout que la
masse on peut être demi en 2 millions et
demi que ça fasse reculer Emmanuel
Emmanuel Macron je n'y crois pas un
instant on ils ont besoin de les
syndicats de se dire ça pour mobiliser
parce que si commence à dire ça servira
à rien bon bah je savais pas comme ça
qu'on va mettre du monde dans la rue
donc c'est c'est normal il faut
comprendre que chacun est en ce moment
en train de tirer au mieux de ce qui
peut avoir comme avantage vous parliez
d'Aurélien Pradier Laurent Berger est
allé le rencontrer quand même en lui
expliquant que toute leur
circonscription fallait qu'il fasse
attention parce que leurs électeurs
quand dans le milieu rural ils sont très
hostiles à cette réforme ce qui m'étonne
moins un peu mais peut-être que je me
trompe voilà mais c'est quand même
intéressant on peut avoir je finis juste
là-dessus peut-être un certain nombre de
députés LR qui reposent sur un électorat
qui soit très sensible aux 62 ans et qui
se disent non quand même j'ai pas
prendre ce risque là mais est-ce que ça
vaut aussi pour les sénateurs
[Musique]
il y a quand même voilà des grands
électeurs des mères de ville où ça va
manifester demain et nous sommes en
question nous sommes dans la chambre des
territoires a priori à l'écoute
justement de ce qui s'est passé dans les
manifestations où tout le monde a
souligné ce qui était un petit peu
surprenant c'est de voir des villes
moyennes voir des des borgades qui se
mobilisaient dans ce mouvement social ce
qui était pas forcément habituel et donc
on pourrait imaginer que pour un certain
nombre de sénateurs le je dirais être se
faire les porte aux paroles de cette de
ce mouvement là qui vient de la France
on va dire de la France profonde ça
pourrait être une motivation auquel cas
le attend de la journée du 7 mars
pourrait avoir un véritable effet mais
je pense que cet effet là ne sera pas
suffisant pour empêcher la marche de la
mécanique parle commentaires et en fait
dans d'un mot quand à deux mots plutôt
et il faut il faut prendre le moindre et
retirer le projet pour Macron Emmanuel
Macron ce serait encore pire que de
l'imposer un peu au forceps comme ça va
être vraisemblablement le cas donc je
veux dire par là que logiquement dans la
mesure où les républicains ont eux
intérêt à ce que ça réussisse au Sénat
est-ce que ça passe au Sénat parce
qu'ils vont un excès le projet et dire
oui c'est nous qui avons fait passer ce
ce projet donc je pense que le malgré
tout la manifestation du 7 mars quel
qu'importance qu'elle est ne réussira
pas à modifier la donne une information
de cette fin de lundi après-midi trois
des quatre terminaux métalliers en
France arrêtez pour 7 jours sur nos
confrères 7 jours sur nos confrères de
de l'Agence France Presse qui nous donne
cette information bref c'est ce que on
disait on va quand même vers une journée
sans doute plusieurs journées ce sera le
thème principal de notre second débat je
veux pas trop le déflorer maintenant
mais vraiment enfin voilà ça ce sont des
jours historiques qui se dressent devant
nous donc on reste sur la partie Sénat
avec vous Mathieu puisqu'on va rentrer
un petit peu dans le dans le détail de
des articles qui ont été votés et
notamment donc
ce CDI senior mesure pour booster
l'emploi des salariés de plus de 60 ans
oui senior c'est un contrat d'embauche
qui présente deux gros avantages sur
l'employeur il est exonéré de cotisation
familiale donc il coûte moins cher et
puis l'employeur peut y mettre un terme
lorsque leur salarié remplit les
conditions d'une retraite à taux prennes
alors c'est une trouvaille du groupe LR
ça casse pas trois pattes un canard faut
le dire à la droite qui a jamais inventé
la poudre en matière de politique de
l'emploi s'en remet une nouvelle fois à
la baisse des charges mais mais mais ça
ne mérite d'exister le gouvernement y
était défavorable on écoute Gabriel
Attal
risque c'est qu'on décale le problème et
que c'est que des personnes qui
aujourd'hui en plus 60 ans et sont au
chômage en fait on décale le problème à
ceux qui sont juste avant 60 ans parce
que eux n'auront pas droit à
l'exonération pour leur employeur s'ils
sont recrutés ça c'est la première chose
sur la deuxième chose c'est un
amendement qui coûte effectivement une
certaine somme alors Gabriel coûte une
certaine
sommeil il y voit un manque à gagner
pour les caisses de la branche famille
entre 800 millions et 2,2 milliards
d'euros selon le ministre budget c'est
un chiffrage que contexte le chef de fil
des sénateurs brunes Retailleau qui lui
se défend en interrogeant à quoi
servirait-il de reculer l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite si on ne fait rien
pour l'emploi des seniors il a pas tout
à fait tort non sur la mesure on peut en
débattre du CDI senior mais sur le fond
oui parce que Gabriel Attal il a beau
jeu d'ironisé on en serait pas là si le
gouvernement avait pris le problème à
bras le corps l'emploi des seniors il
faut le dire c'est un des angles morts
de la réforme pour booster l'emploi des
salariés le gouvernement s'était
contenté de ce fameux index une
obligation faite aux entreprises de
publier des chiffres chaque année sur
l'emploi des seniors un peu comme il
existe un index de l'égalité homme-femme
sur les sur les salaires et là c'est la
mesure a fait beaucoup parler d'elle
pour la simple et bonne raison qu'elle
ne satisfait personne ni la gauche qui
lui reproche de naître avec un gadget
pour faire joli c'est la fameuse faille
de salade au bord de la Sète comme le
disait la député de Paris il s'en est
Rousseau et la droite elle n'y voit que
de la paperasse supplémentaire pour les
entreprises les uns comme les autres
s'accordent au final pour dire qu'au
fond ça sert à rien c'est inefficace
alors pour tenter de corriger le tir le
gouvernement a tenté dans un premier
temps de généraliser son index aux
entreprises de plus de 50 salariés et
non pas de plus de 300 comme elle
l'avait prévu au départ le gouvernement
s'est aussi déclaré favorable à des
pénalités financières toutes symboliques
pour les entreprises qui ne joueraient
pas le jeu mais pas de Paul son
dispositif a été retoqué par l'Assemblée
nationale et donc le voici étoffé par
voie des rendements par voie
d'amendement pardon au Sénat et j'allais
dire faute de mieux et vous pensez qu'il
aurait fallu donc aller plus loin oui
car même si les chiffres se sont
améliorés depuis 20 ans il faut le dire
à la France reste en dessous la moyenne
européenne pour l'emploi des 55 64 ans
on est à 56% contre un peu plus de 60%
pour l'Union européenne et puis le taux
d'emploi n'est plus de 60 ans lui il
dépasse à peine 33% donc l'emploi des
seniors aurait mérité mieux même s'il
était difficile et il faut le
reconnaître de s'atteler vraiment au
problème pourquoi parce qu'on est dans
un projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale rectificative donc tout
ça peut être technique mais en gros si
le gouvernement avait truché ce texte de
mesure pour l'emploi des seniors mais ça
on aurait pris le risque de le voir
retoquer par le considérer
constitutionnel en gros en privilégiant
la tactique pour mener sa réforme au
patchage et ben le gouvernement est
passé à côté d'un vrai sujet merci
Mathieu Raphaël Legendre c'est vrai
qu'il y a vous employez souvent le
l'expression sucrée salée quand on quand
on parle d'une réforme comme comme
celle-là là le le CDI senior c'est du
c'est du sucré d'une certaine façon
parce que ça ça vide enfin ça
déséquilibre le le
j'arrive pas à trouver le mot les
économies qu'on peut faire grâce à grâce
à une thématique
on est territoire d'après 800 millions
de milliards ça me semble un peu
il pousse un peu le trait du côté merci
très certainement c'est une mesure qui
coûterait 800 millions soit en quoi la
droite sénatoriale répond que ça
rapporterait un milliard d'euros en
mettant en 5000 seniors de plus sur le
marché du travail qui cotiserait quand
même toutes les autres cotisations or
famille
donc c'est un incentive comme on dit
c'est une carotte plutôt qu'un bâton
effectivement pour essayer de pousser
vers l'emploi des seniors mais qui est
l'angle mort vous l'avez très bien dit
de ce projet de réforme sur les
retraites souvenez-vous d'Emmanuel
Macron il y a pas si longtemps que ça
qui expliquait en conférence de presse
du mot du temps de sa première réforme
de la réforme à pointe de la retraite
par point donc 2019-2020
c'était bien gentil mais il fallait
peut-être d'abord remettre au travail
les seniors qui aujourd'hui
subissent un taux d'emploi très faible
effectivement c'est un sujet majeur on
est encore confronté à ce sujet
aujourd'hui deux choses si effectivement
le des seniors en France rejoignez le
taux allemand c'est à dire gagner 8 à 10
points on réglerait à peu près tous nos
problèmes de déficit en France c'est un
sujet majeur sur lequel il faut lever
tout il faut actionner tous les leviers
possible donc c'était peut-être ça la
réforme prioritaire et c'était une
grande région qui peut être arrivera par
contre dans un second temps avec la loi
travail d'Olivier du soft sur le bien
travaillé qu'on attend qu'on attend au
printemps mais cette réforme en décalant
de 62 à 64 ans là je légale de départ
fera aussi aura le même effet qu'a eu la
réforme Fillon verte pardon de 2010
c'est-à-dire que mécaniquement on sait
qu'en repoussant l'âge légal de départ
en retraite et bien on fait travailler
davantage de seniors repousse
l'âge de de préretraite des seniors
d'autant ça a repoussé deux ans en 2010
on a augmenté de deux ans on est passé
de 60 à 62 et bien la moyenne des
départs pour les seniors a été repoussé
de deux ans en 10 ans Jean Garry je vous
demande pas de faire des paris dans ce
dans cette émission mais est-ce que cet
article de loi qui a été voté ici cela
il peut survivre à la commission mixte
paritaire d'après vous justement avec
quand on entend les les réticences on va
dire gouvernementales je l'a vraiment je
suis vraiment une question différemment
comment ça comment ça se déroule lors
d'une commission mix par ether Matuidi
tout à l'heure cette cette député cette
sénateur Kitty à la main c'est plutôt
les députés puisque ensuite le dernier
mot revient toujours à l'Assemblée
nationale mais là il faut tenir compte
du rapport de force à l'intérieur
justement de la représentation de
l'Assemblée nationale dans cette
commission mixte paritaire et là si
à l'instar de ce qui devrait se faire
ensuite l'Assemblée nationale se dégage
une majorité faible certes mais des
renaissances et des LR les RR les LR
sera en position à l'intérieur de cette
représentation de l'Assemblée nationale
pour dire bah oui voter notre notre
proposition émanant du Sénat donc a
priori ce serait plutôt en faveur d'un
oui à ce à ce mode oui parce que les le
rapport des forces en ce moment et ça a
été voulu par le par le pouvoir
aujourd'hui il est en faveur des des
républicains ce qui est un paradoxe
parce que on les présentait comme les
grandes victimes de ce qui s'est passé
des élections de 2022 et là dans cette
situation là ce sont eux qui deviennent
les maîtres du jeu il le deviendront à
la commission mixte paritaire de la même
manière juste en terme de rapport de
force la commission mixte paritaire elle
abrite elle abritera 5 parlementaires LR
compte tenu de la majorité qu'ils ont
Sénat plus ils ont quand même un petit
groupe à l'Assemblée et quatre
macronistes et voilà ah E2 les LR et les
macronistes ils ont la majorité de cette
commission x-maritaire mais il faut que
les LR soit admis entre le Sénat et là
c'est
d'accord parce que il est très possible
est-ce que il est possible que les LR de
l'Assemblée ne veuille pas passer sous
les fourches claudines du Sénat et
veuille marquer qu'il se distingue des
sénateurs ils sont
exactement
sur le match retour alors pour l'instant
retailler je vais dire tiens la corde si
au Sénat voilà c'est son moment à lui et
on va avoir le match retour avec cioti
donc c'est c'est pas dit du tout que ça
fonctionne comme ça mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que si ça passe à 64 ans à ce
moment-là la France va retomber dans la
moyenne européenne de la proportion de
gens entre 56 et 64 qui qui travaillent
encore donc c'est là on pourra plus dire
ah là là c'est affreux alors il restera
les plus âgés et effectivement
[Musique]
ne bouge en rien les recettes de la
sécurité sociale ni les dépenses et donc
ce sera très certainement considéré par
le Conseil constitutionnel enfin
d'examen du
ceplffssr comme un cavalier législatif
il sera donc supprimé de texte ce qui ne
changera pas évidemment parce que le
Conseil de la réforme ça veut pas dire
que le pardon nous interrompre que le
Conseil constitutionnel retoque la
totalité d'une expérience
que ce soit pls PLSS il y a certains
articles qui sont autoqués ce ne sont
que des articles et l'index pourrait
tout à fait revenir dans la deuxième loi
travail que portera Olivier du soft au
printemps et on n'a pas du tout parlé
des régimes spéciaux je reste avec vous
Raphaël parce que pour l'instant donc
l'article a été voté
dans la forme voulue par le gouvernement
je ne pense pas me tromper mais la
droite sénatoriale a pas totalement
renoncé à accélérer le rier et à revenir
sur cette clause du grand-père
absolument c'est ça samedi les sénateurs
ont voté effectivement la fin de 5
régimes spéciaux les deux plus
importants étant ceux d'EDF et de la
RATP
avec cette clause du grand-père qui fait
que en fait ce ne sont que les nouveaux
salariés de ces deux entreprises qui
rentreront dans le régime commun mais
vous dites que ça peut revenir
après l'article 7 a déposé un amendement
visant à accélérer la fusion et la
normalisation des régimes d'ici 2040 une
mesure qui permettrait d'ailleurs de
rapporter quelques centaines de millions
voire des milliards d'euros dans un
projet de loi qui je rappelle n'est déjà
plus à l'équilibre il y a eu tellement
de redistribution qu'on a 600 millions
maintenant d'ores et déjà de déficit
alors je vais passer très 13 milliards
et demi à 600 millions c'est une
amélioration très nette mais le texte
n'est plus à l'équilibre à horizon 2030
accélérer la fusion des régimes spéciaux
permettrait l'annulation la suppression
permettrait de rétablir cet équilibre et
alors si ça se passe comme ça c'est
batterie c'est pas un cadeau fait au
gouvernant parce qu'imaginons qu'on est
dans une succession de jours de grève
reconductible et que et que la question
des du régime spécial de la RATP ou
d'EDF revient sur le tapis bon à mon
avis ici toucheront pas on gardera la
clause de grand-père là je pense oui
mais il y a une part de stratégie LR là
pour un petit peu s'abonner la planche
comme vous avez du sable qui dit je fais
une réforme de gauche il y a Retailleau
qui dit aussitôt non non non on est de
droite et on va vous montrer qu'elle est
bien de droite justement donc
l'accélération qui a raison que
je pense que vous avez en tout cas c'est
vous qui avez raison sur le commentaire
voilà mais non je je pense que le
contrat était passé quand on a été
embauché avec cette possibilité d'avoir
cette mise à la retraite dans telle
condition je pense très sincèrement
qu'accélérer le calendrier n'est pas
possible merci beaucoup merci à tous les
trois d'avoir participé à ce premier
débat de sens